Congratulations - you’ve just entered the
employ of the SCP Foundation as a junior researcher!
As you know, the Foundation doesn’t just
hand out positions like this to anyone.
To get scouted as part of their Research Corps,
you need to be one of the best and brightest.
You’re going to be working with strange,
mind-bending, and sometimes even deadly anomalies
on a daily basis.
You’re part of the thin, redacted line between
normalcy and the absolute chaos of the supernatural.
But right now, only one question is on your
mind: Where will you actually be working?
Because here’s the thing: The SCP Foundation
is a worldwide organization devoted to the
containment of the anomalous, and they have
thousands of classified Sites and Areas across
the globe, each of them specializing in a
different subset of the strange.
Depending on your particular area of expertise,
there’s a number of Foundation facilities
you may hope to be assigned to, but that’s
not what we’re talking about today, instead
we’re focusing on the Sites and Areas so
dangerous that just getting assigned there
feels kind of like a demotion to D-Class.
The places with the deadliest anomalies and
the most frightening locales.
That’s right, it’s time to cross your
fingers and hope for the best, because today
we’re going to discuss the most dangerous
SCP Foundation Sites and Areas.
But first, there are some things we need to
understand about Foundation facilities in
general.
If you’re somewhat familiar with the world
of the SCP Foundation, you’ve probably heard
phrases like “Research Site” and “Biological
Containment Area” thrown around a lot.
You may have even picked up most of the meanings
from context clues, but before we throw you
into even more dangerous uncharted waters,
we’re going to break the labels down for
you.
The Foundation has secure facilities all over
the world and they deal with a wide range
of different anomalies, so these facilities
often have to specialize to suit the requirements
of their specific task.
For starters, the terms “Site” and “Area”
aren’t interchangeable.
Sites are covert Foundation facilities that
often exist relatively close to civilian populations.
So as not to arouse suspicion from the public
or rival groups like the Chaos Insurgency,
they disguise themselves as boring government
and corporate buildings.
Areas, on the other hand, typically have to
contain much more dangerous anomalies.
Areas tend to not only be much larger than
Sites, they’re also further away from civilian
population centers.
There’s no cover story here, the Areas are
just entirely hidden.
They also often have some pretty crazy fail-safe
measures in case of a large containment breach,
like one or even multiple nuclear warheads
designed to detonate and blow the whole facility
to kingdom come, if things ever get truly
out of control.
It goes without saying that you’d probably
rather be assigned to a Site than an Area
if you’re risk-averse.
Both types of facilities are divided into
Sections or Sectors, which in some cases are
further divided further into Units.
Units, typically, are small, high-security
areas devoted to the extensive containment
of a single anomaly, or several closely related
anomalies.
Now that you know the two types of facilities,
let’s talk prefixes - the handy little descriptor
that often clues you in to how a Foundation
Site or Area has specialized.
There are ten possible prefixes for a facility,
and we’ll take you on a quick crash course
through those before we start getting dangerous.
“Armed” - as in, Armed Site, Armed Area,
or Armed Section - refers to a facility or
section that possesses a large quantity of
firepower, and could mean military grade weaponry,
vehicles, or just a large number of permanent
armed guards.
Armed facilities tend to be more dangerous
to work in, either due to a greater threat
of containment breach or due to the high possibility
of attacks from the outside.
Biological or “Bio” implies that the facility
or area deals with infectious or biohazardous
anomalies that would make catching the Black
Plague feel like a spa day.
Containment is an obvious one - these sites
or areas that are, you guessed it, built for
containing anomalies.
Dimensional containment facilities or sections
often contain dangerous pocket dimensions
or gateways into other dimensions.
Humanoid containment facilities or sections
deal largely with intelligent human or human-like
anomalies capable of understanding and following
instructions.
They’re similar to standard prisons, but
for anomalous people.
Protected facilities and sections are anomaly-free
safe zones, so we won’t be discussing them
much here.
Provisional facilities are typically temporary
facilities built around an anomaly that couldn’t
be feasibly transported to a pre-existing
facility.
The rare Reliquary facilities or sections
are designed to hold anomalous artifacts of
a religious or historical nature.
Research facilities or sections either research
the anomalies themselves or work on devising
new containment methods, and Storage facilities
are designed to store non-anomalous items
long-term.
The Foundation also has observation outposts
but, with some rare exceptions, your greatest
risk at one of these is dying of boredom.
With that out of the way, let’s get to what
we’ve all been waiting for: The scariest,
deadliest, and most overall dangerous facilities
on the Foundation roster.
The places you’d never want to be assigned
to if your life depended on it, and in this
case it really does.
First, we’ll discuss the most dangerous
sites, and then, the most dangerous areas.
So grab your Foundation-issued sidearm and
let’s go.
First, Site 19.
It shouldn’t be surprising that the largest
operating Foundation Site is also the one
containing some of its most famous and deadly
prisoners.
Two in particular are the one you can’t
look away from, and another that puts you
in lifelong mortal danger if you look at it.
These are SCP - 173, the Sculpture, and SCP
- 689, the Statue of Death.
If you get assigned to Site 19, there’s
a possibility you may suddenly find yourself
with a snapped neck while filling in spreadsheets.
And if you so much as take a glance at SCP
- 689, you’ll be declared an E-Class, and
possibly even terminated by your superiors.
Second, Provisional Site-4511, home of SCP-4511,
also known as The Swine God.
This giant, pig-shaped furnace has had a terrifying
effect on the Foundation personnel stationed
at the Site.
In just a few weeks, it had seemingly rational
researchers and guards performing brutal sacrifices
in its name and descending into an occult
hell.
It’s happened at least once already, and
is extremely likely to happen again, so you
definitely want to avoid being deployed here.
But the most deadly site of all is one that
doesn’t even come from our universe: Site
13, also known as SCP-1730.
This Site, run by Director Elliot Emerson,
functioned like an anomaly slaughterhouse
in another dimension.
Anomalies were murdered and burned, and dissenting
Foundation employees were treated horrifically.
But when Director Emerson happened to turn
on the reality-warping THRESHER machine, this
site became a full-blown nightmare filled
with escaped SCPs, memetic hazards, otherworldly
nightmare gods, and a truly unsavoury entity
nicknamed “Leech Boy” who is quite interested
in drinking your blood.
If you can even survive long enough in Site
13 to meet him, that is.
Of course, it’s the secure Foundation Areas
where the horrors really unfold.
These can make some of the worst sites look
mild in comparison.
Let’s take a look at some of the Foundation’s
most dangerous areas.
First, Containment Area 25b.
This Area is not only 200 meters beneath the
ocean, it’s also one of the most heavily
fortified, and one of the few to actually
detonate its onsite nuclear warhead in the
past.
That’s because this is the containment area
for SCP-076, also known as Able.
This anomaly has frequent and extremely violent
containment breach attempts, often brutally
slaughtering staff in the process with his
deft swordsmanship.
Accepting a job here is a great way to fast
track yourself into becoming human sushi.
Next up is Area-354.
This facility houses SCP-354, also known as
the Blood Pond, a slowly expanding pool of
red liquid that habitually unleashes dangerous
monsters that attack the guards stationed
there.
These include giant bats, huge metal spheres
releasing concentrated radiation beams, a
giant reptilian humanoid impervious to gunfire,
and an invisible, robotic “Terminator”
entity that managed to murder 90% of the attending
guards before being killed itself.
In other words, not a recipe for stable employment.
Area-126 is dangerous for a number of reasons.
First, that it’s located inside war-torn
Damascus, Syria, and thus sometimes comes
under threat from shelling operations.
Second, because it contains SCP-3989.
This spatial anomaly in the middle of an olive
orchard turned out to be a front for a terrifying
Sarkic dimension full of fleshy abominations.
What’s more, simply being in this area slowly
caused the staff to lose their minds and become
devoted to the Sarkic deities hidden within
the dimension.
And much like the blood pond, it’s believed
that this area of influence is actively growing
day by day, meaning if you work at Area-126
it’s actually getting less safe with each
moment that passes.
Next, Armed Reliquary and Containment Area-02.
This base is specifically designed to contain
highly dangerous, hostile, or otherwise hazardous
anomalies, including multiple Keter-class
objects.
And we’re not kidding when we say dangerous
and hostile.
The anomalies housed on this site are so dangerous
there’s a literal battalion of armed guards
to keep the peace.
It also has not one but multiple fail-safe
nuclear weapons, designed to literally erase
the entire base from existence if ever there’s
a catastrophic containment breach.
One particularly horrifying anomaly in Area-02
is SCP-743.
This is a seemingly innocent chocolate fountain
that actually contains billions of extremely
violent, ant-like creatures that will swarm
anything nearby, tearing it to pieces and
dragging the pieces back to their nest inside
the fountain.
These insects will stop at nothing and can
ever tear through titanium if they need to
in order to get their desired sustenance,
so being present in this Area means your life
is constantly at risk.
Hope you like chocolate.
Next is the dreaded Armed Biological Containment
Area-14, which contains some of the deadliest
biological anomalies out there.
From the bloodthirsty, kill-crazed heart of
darkness SCP-058, to the head-devouring cannibal
giant SCP-082, to the voice-imitating, memory
wiping red pack hunters SCP-939.
This base also houses several fast-breeding
killer parasites and a few highly infectious
and deadly diseases.
While Area-14 does boast an entire army of
guards with heavy military hardware for preventing
all these terrifying monsters from breaching
containment and causing havoc, that probably
won’t make you feel much better.
If even one of these things escapes at any
given time, you better hope for your family’s
sake that you have a good life insurance policy.
And finally, Area-37.
As it stands, being sent to this area pretty
much guarantees either death or a fate even
worse than dying.
That’s because Area-37 is no longer under
the control of the SCP Foundation.
Instead, it’s become a twisted playground
for SCP-1765, a trio of terrifying reality
warpers known as The Sisters.
These unstoppable monsters claimed the Area
as their own and began performing sickening
experiments, such as being forced into maddening
time loops designed to drive you insane or
being crushed and burned to death in deadly
games with confusing rules.
While heading into other areas offers the
possibility of a gruesome fate, Area-37 offers
a dead certainty.
Now, not only do you now know the difference
between different types of sites and areas,
you now know some of the most horrifying and
deadly examples of each, so you know which
to avoid.
But look on the bright side, if you’re hard
up for work and the SCP Foundation seems like
an appealing job, at least you know there’ll
likely always be a position available at one
of these sites.
After all, positions here open up very frequently...
Now go check out SCP-4511 The Swine God and
SCP-1765 Sisters for even more on the SCP
Foundation’s deadliest sites and areas.